[Music]  all right Joe from food Wars we're  shooting a laze chips episode so I want  to tell you my three favorite lace chips  and one type of Chip I can't stand this  is more of a chip style I love the wavy  chips like a thicker chip this is the  ranch flavor these are fantastic I do  surprisingly enough love the lemon  flavored chips you either love them or  hate them I love them my favorite chips  are the jalapeno kettle chips kettle  chips are my favorite style of Chip and  the jalapeno flavor is spicy and so  flavorful and one thing I cannot stand  that I never like and I also encourage  you to never eat as well or anything  baked they all taste like cardboard they  never have any flavor less fat what they  mean it's got less flavor I don't like  any baked chips no no to these get  regular chips just don't get them at all